if you don't know there's such a thing
as an archetype itself
you will tend to have ways in which you
are unconsciously identified with it
so in other words if uh if if
and this is one of the important thing
about young psychology
because if jung is correct
as i'm convinced that he is that there
is
an incredibly powerful
agent in the psyche
that contains codes
for the individual process
and yet is loaded with
extremely high voltage energy
then if you don't know
that there is this great thing i like to
call it the god self
because uh jung talked about the
archetype itself is the god imago
the you you can say it's the some would
say it's the image
the imago dei but
i don't like us uh putting it that way
because that implies that it's just a
image in the psyche and it's not a
living
presence in the psyche and so what
what i would say that they if you don't
if there's a living presence in your
psyche
and it has tremendous knowledge
of the ground plan for your optimal
development
and yet it has enormous energies
that if if you cannot relate to them
consciously
you will either spend too much of your
life without a conscious connection to
those energies
or you may be connecting with those
energies
uh in an unconscious way and uh having
and those energies do not manifest
positively in your psyche
so so this is why it's in my personal
view
uh it's so important that people
understand the the that the
this jung's idea of the archetypal self
this organizing center in the psyche
but also this enormous generator of of
energy in the psyche generator of
extremely powerful energies in the
psyche
if you don't know about that and you're
either just projecting that
center on other people
or you're identifying with it and you're
a narcissistic personality disorder
uh this this is got a lot of
implications
so one of the things that i think is
important for us to think about this
evening
uh is that uh if you do not know
about
this psychological entity in the psyche
you are very vulnerable to
uh to having it manifest in ways which
you have no idea
uh in which you have no idea what is
happening and there
and if you're not conscious of it and
conscious of the need to relate to it
consciously
which uh is what i'm saying the capacity
to relate to
that great thing within you consciously
then you are at a great disadvantage
in life so uh so
uh the getting to that figure four it's
easier to talk about
getting to that point than it is to
actually have a living relationship to
the archetypal self
i uh i i think
however that jung was clear about this
and edinger was amazingly
clear about the
central role of of getting to get some
understanding
in your life about how you are in fact
related
to the energies of the archetypal self
and
and uh what connecting with that energy
probably uh is doing to you in your life
so let me just proceed here